so hello everyone I believe we can start
welcome I'm really really happy that I'm
here today I'm really happy that you are
here today you have quite brave ones I
believe because it's quite advanced talk
I mean probably it will be maybe not we
will see and so my name is Connie otra
cosa and then what is the agenda for
this talk it is solely about writing
your own custom dotnet GC we do this
every day so that's this talk is about
and the agenda will be why we can never
care about writing something like that
like our custom dotnet GC what happe
what we have to do to write something
how to write something that is working
at least a little and then how to write
something that tries to be at least a
bit a little useful at least start
writing it as we will see it is not so
easy thing to do as you can expect I'm
why this topic in general I'm a guy
related to dotnet performance and the
internal stuff I really like such a
stuff I wrote this book which is two to
one thousand page about dotnet memory
management it should be automatic but it
still have some caveats and I when I
started writing it I just was writing
writing writing can't it took 1000 pages
to describe all the stuff I'm a
co-founder or dotnet was initiative
which is also about talking about
performance scalability internal stuff
related all about dotnet an advanced way
of seeing it I'm also on Twitter if you
like follow me I almost I'm always
smiling when someone starts to follow me
see it is yeah so welcome to the world
of the custom disease which in case of
dotnet does not exist so much or maybe I
should say it does not exist at all
because we have only one VC in.net that
you can choose from I mean choose from
because there is no choice we have the
only one default GC it is but why why we
even care about something like dotnet
customs GC maybe you have used J
maybe have used Java on other a JVM
language and people from JVM are quite
used to things like custom disease they
have are several disease that they can
choose from and number is growing so
they have constantly new disease that
they can use and yeah they have a flag
that they allows them to choose which DC
they are using moreover they have a lot
of configurations that allows them to
fine-tune how those disease are working
it ends up as copy pasting code from
Stack Overflow just to get a good set of
parameters but obviously joking for sure
it is powerful things like they can
really fine-tune what are they today
needs what what do you see they want to
use what parameters they want to use
what they how they be should they be
configured and yeah because when we're
talking about you see there is nothing's
like a civil ballot that will be just
enough for every possible scenario we
can look at disease from various
perspectives we can look out for example
about and think about memory overhead of
GC whether it is really aggressive in
releasing memory or maybe totally not
what is the CPU overhead what is the
resource resources use of the VC what is
the resulting throughput what pulses are
introduced by the team do you see there
are a lot of possibilities how this DC
can behave in various scenarios because
our applications are obviously different
we have different workloads so there is
nothing like very powerful one generic
DC that will just behave in good in
every possible scenario in case of
dotnet as I said there is only one DC so
in fact you have this simple
configuration knobs like whether you
want to your server DC or workstation DC
on whether it should be concurrent or
not but it is still the same DC it's in
terms of logic and lengths of algorithm
it is still the same DC those flags
obviously influence how they will work
but it is still the same algorithm so
the choice is not so sophisticated here
in fact we have some additional
configuration knobs that can
additionally find Huhn those this
default DC but still it is the only one
so the second approach here is that was
recently added in case of dotnet core it
was to go to the second the highest
possible level of customization and now
you can just write your own custom GC
which is quite powerful feature that I
would like you to describe here so what
can be done with such custom writing own
custom GC possibility in fact you can
replace the whole GC mechanism and this
is the sole purpose here you and that
you can just get rid of the current one
and replace it with the completely new
written by you it would be a little bit
more harder to fine-tune and change
something in the current one like I have
this default one and I wants to change
this little thing here or there and that
would be harder easier approach is here
just to get rid of everything can't
replace it with something new the
ultimate goal then probably would be to
write something better than the current
GC good luck obviously because it is
written for a lot of years and this
really powerful thing a really
well-written so obviously this is a goal
which is quite far let's say the
practical one goal would be just write
anything that works and compiles and
doesn't crash the runtime
it's quite quite good goal as for the
beginning so from the well from the
world how pirates sees the world there
is a map and we go and we try to reach
this island which is island with the
treasure which is a concurrent
compacting ultimate GC which is much
better than the current one which is
obviously very hard to be there and to
be there we need to start from somewhere
and I just always when I decided to do
something like custom GC I decided to
write something like minimal valuable
product which is a kind of 0 DC it is a
well known
name like zero DC which is quite strange
to see because only allocating objects
it's only put policies to allocate
objects and it is not reclaiming memory
after it totally so there is no DC at
all in fact we are only able to allocate
something and this is a called 0 DC and
I thought ok this is a good idea because
it is the simplest thing that you can
imagine right just something like that
and so we start from this 0 DC island
and here we will try to implement
something that compiles plugs into the
runtime and doesn't crash anything this
is quite good set of requirements I said
a bit for the beginning and it might be
the idea of the 0 DC seems quite strange
or funny or may make no sense at all but
in fact there are some disease like for
example in the JVM or world there is a
epsilon G C it is quite good name like
it means it sounds quite wise it is
still 0 DC it is only responsible for
allocating objects and no opt a garbage
collector and it some salt proposes that
it handles memory allocations but does
not implement memory reclamation at all
exactly like I would like to do in case
of dopant and talking about epsilon GC
or mine my is 0 GC we can think about
how can be the motivation the why we
would ever write something like that and
epsilon GC has provided quite a nice set
of motivations that I just would like to
provide you because it they quite nicely
explained the idea like for example when
we have something like epsilon GC or 0
GC it is good for performance testing
because we have nice baseline we have
the the simplest possible GC that we
plugged in into the runtime and then
when we will be writing something more
sophisticated we will have a baseline to
compare with because there is nothing
simpler than 0 GC also memory pressure
testing is a good name for I have a
memory leak by default so when I have a
memo
when I do not reclaim an old memory for
sure I will see how the memory
consumption grows in my application if
it is heavy allocating or not so then I
will be able to quite fastly and
discover that for example my application
is heavy allocating and I need to tune
it now somehow also obviously when we
have this virtual machine at the run
time and we have the DC writing 0 DC the
simplest possible to see is a quite nice
way of testing the whole interface with
the contract between the runtime and the
GC so writing it it is a good way to
know whether the contract is well
designed or not also more practical
approach like in the use case for
extremely short leaf living objects for
extremis all living jobs like several
functions when we know that the function
will be just running for a minute maybe
there is no sense in running GC because
we know that the process will close
shortly so why we should bother about
reclaiming memory so in terms of very
short living objects the jobs processes
the quite nice possibilities just to get
rid of the GC totally and the same
encasing last drop latency improvements
when we have a application that almost
completely is garbage free it almost no
allocates a lock is almost no memory it
is also good to get rid of GC because we
have put so much effort to not allocate
that getting rid of the GC totally may
be beneficial for us so maybe to
practical use cases of such exotic GC
and additionally for me it is a quite
good template like when I have a such as
0 GC it is a perfect place to start to
implement something more sophisticated
also a lot of learning because I need to
learn a lot about how the GC cooperates
with the runtime and how this all
couples and this is a great opportunity
to learn something new and also quite a
lot for me a lot of fun like maybe I'm a
nerd but for me it was a fun also that
something I'm was
able to write right and it doesn't crash
the runtime so that's a summary why you
even care something about customs you
see first of all because maybe the
default configuration possibilities are
quite limited for us and we want to
write something that is more fine-tuned
to our needs maybe we need GC because we
have very specific workload very
specific needs and now we have this
possibility that we can replace it
totally so it is quite nice maybe we can
write something more configurable it
depends on our needs and because
obviously we can learn a lot about the
runtime out about the GC about the
memory management but it is important to
remember that it is not because the
current default GC is wrong I mean it is
really awesome so it is really really to
cut up and writing something better and
we should not start just writing custom
GC because we believe that in a year or
two we will just write something better
probably will be not able to do that so
it is not the case here so what we have
to do to write some at custom GC it is
called local GC in terms of internal
microsoft terminology the project was
was was called local DC in the old
repository between before the merge of
repositories the project was called
local GC and what is interesting here
that it has been cancelled like it has
been implemented it has been merged into
the dotnet core but at some point the
the work on it has stopped totally so as
we see here the last issues within this
project are from two years ago
because someone has did it and just left
the company and the whole project has
been left but at least they left it in a
way that it is a we were we are able to
compile it were able to consume it some
work is still for sure to be done like
some more diagnostic some more things
that are maybe not so important but
still should be added so this is kind of
the project that is on the production
can be
but for sure need some more polishing
from Microsoft but how we can use it it
is very simple obviously it is only for
dotnet core and to use it we just need
to set a single environment variable
that just tells you this library from
now implements are my custom GC and when
the runtime will be just starting it
will look at this environment variable
and we'll just load the GC code from
this library so yeah quite easily we
need just a single file with the library
library with the DC code quite easy
thing what to do to implement such like
such library
obviously we need unmanaged code we need
probably C++ code because the whole
runtime is written in C++ it is good
because we only need to include three
files it is quite good the coupling
between the runtime and the DC because
three files in case of the whole runtime
is a very small number and then we need
to implement two methods that will be
exported I will explain them shortly and
implement the rest of the GC yes right
just to implement few interfaces which
reminds me that it is not so easy to do
because we need some very deep knowledge
in fact how this GC will cooperate with
the runtime we have this interface but
we need to intervene to understand this
interface so on the one hand we just
need to write library that include three
files implement few classes few
interfaces on the other hand we just
need to write the whole GC which reminds
me this picture like just include few
files and then write the rest of the GC
easy okay but talking about those
exported methods the very first one is
very easy in fact because it is called
version info it will be called by the
runtime to check what GC API
our library supports because the GC API
is version 8 so the runtime will check
whether it understand this specific API
of the GC but it is easy we are just
provides two numbers then we need method
also easy method which is called
initialize that provides the pointer
style custom DC implementation so we
need just to set those two pointers that
are talking saying that from now let's
replace the pointer to default DC with
the pointer to my own custom
implementation of the DC so it is also
very easy function we also need to
remember this pointer which is called
IGC to CLR interface which provides very
nice features like we will be using
Kito's features like for some time at
some moments our DC will need to ask the
runtime for something and this interface
allows us to do that so yeah this is a
heap file is the hardest one to
implement there is a constructor it is
easy it is C++ and then we have those
set of methods a lot of methods and this
might be quite scary like okay I need to
implement all those methods so probably
I will do it for a month or two or one a
year and yes it can be a little bit
scary but in fact what we really do have
to implement in those in this interface
when we look at them about the
cooperation between the runtime and the
GC we see that obviously we have this AI
the GC to the CLR interface and we have
this which is implemented by the runtime
and we have a GC heap but when we look
at the methods of this interface we
looked at a lot of them currently are
highly coupled with the current
implementation like for example there is
a method set large of Jacob compaction
mode but we don't have a concept of
large of the heap in our custom DC so
this method will not make sense for us
to implement also methods like if object
is being promoted my GC may have no
concept of promotion so also this will
not make sense to implement it and a lot
of such matters will be just because of
the current coupling between the default
and a default DC and the runtime and
only a few will be really need to be
implemented this is a good news so what
we have to do it does write simple C++
library and implement those
interfaces mostly by providing some
dummy implementation for most of the
methods we will see its own so how we
can write something working on this zero
to see island there is a very first step
called colored based zero DC it is a DC
our locating objects with the help of
so-called kalach might not collect
function which is a function provided by
the windows api and as i said most of
the methods can be done e because we
don't care like if the runtime is asking
whether the runtime structures are valid
let's say they are let's assume they are
if the object is being promoted it is
not because we don't have promotion in
our GC or when what was the last DC
collected what was the last generation
collected I don't have concept of
generation so let's just return zero a
lot of such matters will be implemented
in such one-line way of implementing
them because it is just enough and the
most important method that is probably
for us is like a method guide but
garbage collect which is called by the
runtime if the runtime asks us to make a
garbage collection we will just say okay
I am done there was no errors and that's
all one line because we don't have GC
but in fact this method is called not so
very often because this is a method when
we for example called GC collect in
c-sharp code which we should not do it
or for example when the operating system
asked us to make GC so it is quite not
very often path most much more often
puffs of triggering disease allocation
because this is how the GC is working
when the runtime wants to a new app new
object when we are new ink up new object
in c-sharp code it makes we it means we
are making so-called allocation and this
allocation is calling those two methods
and the two main responsibilities of
those methods are we need to get an
object I mean I mean we need to get an
address of a memory for this object and
also at some point in time probably we
will need to
tract that we are running out of memory
and we will like to trigger GC and this
really 99% of disease happens in this
path that alligator is seeing that it is
running out of space for us it is good
news because we don't trigger GC so we
will just not trigger GC from within
these methods we will just be creating a
space for a new object and return an
address of this memory and we will be
doing it with the help of colic it is a
very simple C sharp Cutlass sorry C++
code that is just using
kalach which is system a system call
that returns you and the rest of us few
bytes because allocation just asked for
a given amount of bytes for a new object
and this is dull and this is the whole
alligator it is every time you create an
object you ask the system to get a
memory for it so it is obviously not
very not optimal way of doing things but
at least this should work yeah so this
is the allocation then we have to handle
handles handles are very important topic
in the.net runtime like we have pinned
handles strong handles the string
interning is using handles a lot of
handles are being used internally and we
need to implement it but it is again
quite easy implementation is just
operating on an array of handles and
putting pointers in such for such array
I would not explain it here but it is
really really easy code even that I just
hard-coded the maximum number of handed
handles because I was lazy enough not to
make this the collection dynamic so I
have handles of maximum 65,000 handles
and the handling those handles is pretty
easy so this is hole in fact this is the
color by zod see only few lines of code
that most of them are just done
implementation allocator that is calling
color and you can look at this code in
my repository compile it and plug in on
the production on your production
servers we will see what will happen
just tweet me about the results and
obviously we need to set the environment
viable like we need to provide a path to
this dll that is implementing such 0gc
you can also use lunch settings JSON
file it depends on you
that's easy and the result was I was
quite surprised that first of all it
worked like oh my god it doesn't cross
the run time and I was load testing
asp.net core application with the help
of it so I just provided very simple Web
API that was returning some values and I
was load testing it and maybe you will
able to see it or not maybe the numbers
are too small probably they are in case
of the normal SP dot not core
application I was able to process during
the load test 700 requests per seconds
and this was a normal full speed of not
core with the normal default full DC and
in coils of my 0 DC being plugged into
the runtime I was able to process almost
700 requests per second I was quite
surprised because it's the same number
almost so very trivial DC written in a
few hours was able to match the same
performance I don't know if what it says
about the VC or why DC but yeah this is
the difference that I was quite shocked
obviously there are some differences
that we can measure like this is a
memory usage visible for the asp.net
full version I mean as B does not call
with the full DC we see that the memory
used is stable because this is working
so it reclines memory and the CPUs it's
the smaller graph then the blue one is
quite low so the CPUs it was the CPU
overhead was quite low on the other hand
this is the minor version so we have a
memory by default we can really fastly
measure how fast how we allocate also
the GC is kicking in because I mean the
CPU is very high it has a very high
usage because of this color code for
every obey object being created we call
the operating system to ask for memory
so it is really not optimal way we
consume a lot lot of memory I and a lot
more CPU but
it worked and it was able to sustain
[Music]
23,000 requests without crashing so
magic happened here that it was able to
rock so as a summer it was quite easy to
write something like that
it the cooperation does in fact the
separation between the runtime and the
GC turned out to be quite nicely
designed there were some caveats like we
I need to do some magic to get rid of
the so-called write barriers that I'm
not covering here because it is kind of
too advanced for a such a talk but you
can refer to the articles that I'm
providing you at the end of this
presentation but they were not so very
hard to overcome so it took me only I
don't know 15 minutes to overcome and
also it is quite easy to upgrade it to
something more sophisticated like get
rid of the color call in a locator and
use so called bump pointer a locator
which is more sophisticated more optimal
way of doing allocations which provided
less quite significantly smaller City
usage with the same results so it was
nice also that we can improve it and so
you can take this code play around with
it and maybe we'll do something more
useful from that and how we can write
something useful in fact please meet the
epsilon GC I just decided to name my
reward you see I mean a fancy name and
asked the epsilon disease in the Avion I
obviously decided to write something
better so I'm using better a Greek
letter for that they have epsilon you
see I have epsilon G C epsilon G C is a
living on a completely new Island
because now if we start to reclaim
memory we are living the 0 GC which is
only allocating and we just need to get
somehow to the zero to this epsilon
Epsilon Island which will be able to in
fact reclaim memory that we are creating
so it will be kind of reward to see that
we can plug into our servers and
because we are doing really development
now we need to debug something I was
quite surprised at the previous one I
was able to implement without even
debugging because just few trials was
enough to see what was what what crashes
and what I should change but here I
really need to debug the the back both
of my custom GC and the back the runtime
so I need the debug version of the
runtime I need to build the runtime the
debug version I need to build my custom
DC in a debug version so yeah that was a
something really important at this step
so we need to check out the runtime have
you ever compiled the runtime the
corsola runtime to two hands few hands
it takes like 10 minutes it depends on
the power of your computer then you have
your own version of the runtime which
you can debug step by step because it
will be in the back ration and probably
nose verse in this scenario it is really
useful because we need need you need to
understand what is going on so we really
need to debug it after those 10 minutes
you will have this and then it is not so
easy to utilize even at such a runtime
because you have a runtime but runtime
depends a lot of many other libraries
managed ones the managed ones that
somehow cooperate with the runtime and
it is not so easy to take your custom
runtime and your not run your own
application on it it is not so trivial
to make those things cooperate so the
easiest way in fact is do something like
so compile your application in so called
self-contained mode you publish your
application in so called self-contained
mode it means that this application will
be compiled and deployed all together
with the runtime so the whole runtime
will be within the folder of the
application and then you have this debug
version of your runtime you just copy
pasting the your own custom version of
the runtime over the files in this
self-contained application then you will
be able to run your application with the
help of
our custom debug version of the runtime
mics this is not I'm mentioning it
because it is not so trivial I mean I
was quite surprised that we need to do
some kind of copy pasting magic to run
something useful on the custom version
of the runtime and after doing that we
need something when you have some
application that we will be running
because we need some code to be tested
and then we have our custom debug
version of the runtime and a deal begins
for me an idea is just the time that I'm
just kind to the need for this
presentation it is a third driven
development like there is no
documentation about custom GC I mean I
have a custom GC interface and now I
need to write it but I don't know how
because there is no documentation and
luckily in debug mode the runtime has a
lot of assets and in fact those it is
less forgiving
we should really not be able to do
something which we harmful because icon
the runtime contains so many authors
inside and it is good for us because in
the lack of documentation asserts simply
drive our development because we are
hitting assets and we start to
understand ok in this scenario this
assert failed so I probably should do
this or that this is a kite side of
doing things but at least we have
something so when we started to the very
first run of my custom console hello
world application run on the custom
debug version of the runtime with my
custom GC plugged in I hit the very
first assert and then I will need to
understand ok at some point I'm seeing
that during allocation of some array
some object is being checked whether it
is into the hip or not it turns out that
in fact the runtime at some point is
calling this method this hip pointer
which means the runtime is asking
whether this particular object is be
allocated by the GC and for my 0dc it
was just enough to say if it is not null
okay
I'm it is allocated by me because I was
allocating everything like that but in
case of my more sophisticated absolute
epsilon GC I need to have some more
logic here to answer the right question
to provide the right answer to this
question so I started to track what
objects in fact I really allocated by my
code so I started to track segments and
now I'm able to ask for with the proper
and the problem I give the value
transfer whether an object has been
allocated by me or not it was quite easy
change driven by the assert because I
just hit some assert during the
development and the whole story
continues like that I mean how
everything is about a third and then
because epsilon this is the real world
this is so I need those two steps like
mark-and-sweep
because it is living on the mark and
sweet violent so it is not 0 DC anymore
I need those two mark two phases marking
phase and sweep phase the mark face is
the one that marks all the objects that
are living so I need to know what
objects are living so far so I should
not reply memory after them and they I
will have a sweet face that will just
mark out all those which are no longer
used as a free space to be reused
obviously I'm assuming the simplest
non-concurrent approach because it is
too hard to write something concurrent
and in fact it ends that my Upsilon GGC
is going to trigger GC at allocation
path if it is running out of memory
which I have somehow will track I don't
know how it will mark all objects in all
segments my maintained by me which means
I will just notice which objects are
still reachable which objects are still
live and then I will sweep you news
unused objects into free space like I
will mark all the space after they're no
longer needed objects as a free space to
be
in the future as new places for
allocating objects so the very first
think now we need is just to write the
code that we'll be able to do very
simple thing I need because my algorithm
is non-concurrent one I need to suspend
the whole everything I need in factor to
suspend I need to suspend all the
threads in my application and there is
this API provided by the I DC I CLR to
DC interface which has this very nice
method suspend ie which is just asking
the runtime to suspend all the threads
in our application because I need to do
something I need to do the GC and then I
would like to call obviously to call
restart EE which is just asking the
runtime to risk the resume all the
threads to proceed with they work so
this is quite easy I will just calling
this and I obviously what happened when
I ran it assert because it's like
development is driven by a certain
mother case so it turns out that for
example I'm not able to call suspend EE
if there is no the suspense is expecting
the method is in DC in progress to say
that yes the GC is in progress okay
so let's make a flag global flag disease
in progress and my new is DC in progress
method will just return this value of
this flag I'm now tracking whether
really I'm now doing GC or not
and yes I'm setting this flag to true
before calling suspending and doing some
things that I will be doing here and
then I'm calling the setting this flag
to false and suspending resuming all the
threads with the help of rs30 method and
obviously what happened here an assert
now an assault happened at the level of
the resumed runtime because it turns out
that the resumed our runtime is
expecting that SDC is not in progress
which was
it surprised I mean it is expecting that
it will be in progress it shouldn't be
not in progress and it turns out that
West RTE says this flag by its own so
again by data third
I discovered that something that
something like that should be said to
fulfill its expectations so restart EE
just says that this flag to false by
this all so now after only two asserts
of have a proper valid code that is able
to suspend all the threats for my own
needs then I will do some magic and then
I will just resume in the work assuming
their threats and that's nice quite easy
if you pass all these assert driven
errors so then I will need to start
doing some serious job because I'm just
only able now to suspend threats which
is not so sophisticated and the real
work here starts from scanning what are
the living objects in my application and
I need to start from so-called roots I
have a lot of various types of roots in
application the most typical ones are
the stock roots when your application is
running you have a method in these
methods you have local variables and
those method variables are the roots of
your objects because they are just
keeping those objects are life you have
local viable so this is representing a
root for some object so I need an API to
scan all those local variables and
luckily there is such an IP I provided
it is called GC scan roots and you just
provide a nicole back for it and this
callback will be called for every object
discovered as being rooted by the stack
by the local variable by your methods so
quite easy again think you provide this
callback and then you are able to scan
all the roots on the local variables on
the methods being executed when you
suspended the code and when you suspend
it all the threats and obviously then we
need to scan
other type of roots in cars of our oops
alone GC we have only two types of roots
in fact we have only local roots local
variables roots and handles handles it
is much easier to handle because we are
owner of the handle stable so scanning
it is just going through our own array
of handles because we know all the
details of this handles array so it is
even easier and obviously we need to
implement all this thing like it is a
poster which shows the current
implementation of the GC in.net and we
just have written we have just written a
very simple if you erase from this how
it really should work and this is just
to compare the complexity we just here
starting to implement it and yes so we
have this code which should be quite
nicely quite nice start of work for the
further development we are stunning
scanning the roots the local ones and
scanning the handles roots from the
handles and I was quite surprised but it
just worked I mean there was no assert
anymore I was just able to print all
local objects that are keeps alive by
the scan by the study by this local
viable fruits and handles I was very
happy seeing this screen I miss very
happy seeing this result because now it
means I'm something to start from there
are those objects from which I should
start to traverse all the whole graph
because they are the very beginning of
the whole graph we will see here a
magical numbers like their confirmation
that it is really working is that a lot
of those objects are strings and my my
example application was allocating a lot
of strings so yeah it means that it is
working I have a lot of strings as a
local variables doing the DC happened
and try to do some work
but it is a very easy step like you
discover all the roots on the stack or
in the handles now we need to do
something more sophisticated like we
need to start to traverse the whole
object graph and we know that this
particular object is alive because it
has a local variable or in some method
but now I need to traverse it so it
means I need to go from this object to
another objects that are referenced by
this object and then to go through the
all the references from these particular
objects to the all objects that it
refers so we need to traverse all the
object graph and this is kind of really
tricky because currently there is no API
for that and it was at this point I was
very sad and disappointed because there
is no API to discover that ok I have an
address than an object and now I need to
know what this object points to what are
the references inside this object that I
should follow to discover what is being
reachable because this object is being
alive so there is no API for that I'm
working on it to add it to the core CLR
code because it is just it does not make
sense to have all this custom we see
without such API because at this is a
blocker simply I'm not able to traverse
the object graph so it doesn't make
sense to write an ADC without such API
so as a summary the development of such
custom GC is really a third driven
development there is no documentation I
should probably write some or maybe
Microsoft should probably write some
because you there is nothing to start
from yeah besides my it simple up tries
here and maybe that's because only few
people in the world are interested in
writing custom don't know GC but still
if there is such project probably it
should being as left in the state that
is usable so a documentation here could
be quite nice to have it was quite easy
to utilize the suspend to restart
capability to suspend and restart all
the threats it was very easy to find the
stock routes it was also nice even
easier to find the handle routes because
we manage them and currently the whole
thing is blocked because we are not able
to traverse the object graph because we
don't know those River and references
outgoing from a particular object so the
whole project is postponed and blocked
by by the lack of this API the rest is
just the sea of unknown here like I
don't know what problems I will meet in
the future for sure there will be a lots
of problems and so what's next what's
next for me for sure the very first step
is to add this API of traversing objects
or maybe asked Microsoft to add such API
because without it it doesn't make sense
I'm living here starting to live here on
this Upsilon island trying to implement
those things grassing trying retrying
trying to implement it and there is this
concurrent compacting GC which should be
our target because the main difference
between the current dotnet GC and some
newest this is available for JVM they
are about the able to compact during the
application is working the current
dotnet GC is not able to do that so we
need to stop all the threats to compacts
memory why in JVM words we have at least
through this is that able to compact
memory why the application is working
which is quite a hard topic because we
are moving objects why we are using them
so it is obviously not so easy task and
this is for me the goal here to try to
implement something like that so I'm
trying to get there somehow currently
I'm starting this epsilon Island I'm
trying to find this treasure here to
everyone be happy and probably it will I
mean I'm maybe sometime it will happen
if you like such things there is a geet
repository for that you can just start
to help me if you like C++ and memory
management if you really like to do
something like that there is a perfect
book about garbage collection if in
general very Academical one like this is
a very dense book about every possible
GC algorithm that has been invented so
far it describes this in details in very
Academical way but after it you will
just know everything but then you will
need to implement it somehow because
it's mostly about not the implementation
details is mostly about how they work as
a concept obviously my book if you are
interested in how the current is dotnet
GC is working and if you'd like to know
a little bit more details about this
particular zero these implementations I
also refer you to those two articles
from my blog about those Caviar's about
writing write barriers some more details
if you get if you got interested and in
fact that's all thank you it was quite
fast do you have any questions do you
feel encouraged to write your own custom
DC yeah as far as I know I'm the only
guide trying to use it so probably no
but I don't know maybe they are doing
this there is good question because in
JVM words it's happening like there are
companies providing their own runtimes
with their own batter disease so there
is a field for a business probably but
for now I don't I'm not a very friendly
of like that yep
as far as I know this project has been
created by a summer intern thus has left
after the summer and probably he left
this at the same status I'm now so he
didn't implement anything really
real-world like he just decoupled it
provide the contract compile it and yeah
then they stopped the work has stopped
but maybe they have some I'm I don't
know some implementations yep which one
with a github repository link yeah okay
it was just somewhere at the beginning
maybe other question when I'm just
growing
it is really yeah currently it is not
possible because there is no such API
for traversing those objects you can
write your own I mean you can copy paste
the code from the runtime to custom this
is trying to do that but then you will
be highly coupled with the current
implementation the runtime should
provide this API not your own decision
know the internals of the runtime to use
this logic so all as it is possible now
no one guarantees that the future
version of the runtime will change a
little bit how it organized internally
so your copy pasted code will be no
longer valid so we could try but I would
rather not to go that direction I'm just
trying to get this IP I working and
other questions yep yep I'm not sure I
didn't receive any direct feelings I
don't know what they think I probably
maybe I just should ask directly I know
that they are of that we were talking
about that but I believe this project
for them is very high I mean the lowest
priority possible like someone did it
and someone like me just started to use
it and because I'm the only one in the
world
the priority is high quite low here but
maybe I should start asking them
directly ok and other questions if not
thank you and see you on the github
repository just create some pull
requests er thank you
[Applause]